curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video
so we've been very concerned for months
now about a possible sequel to the
january 6 trump riots and really ever
since the organizers started planning
this event for washington dc on
september 18th
we've been worried about whether there
would be another violent confrontation
another insurrectious coup attempt or
whatever else the case may be now
september 18 2021 you might notice if
you look at the calendar that date is
now in the past this was this past
saturday
and the reason for the fears of violence
was that as as much as the point of the
rally could be understood and we'll get
to how
it sort of wasn't even clear what the
point of the rally was as much as we
could understand the point of this rally
it was to support what the
rally-goers believe is unfair treatment
of the alleged trump rioters from
january 6. the if there was any theme
and it was so disjointed if there was
any theme at the saturday event
it was that the september 18th
protesters feel
that those accused of of rioting on
january 6th are being held illegally
without good reason in poor jail
conditions not being given good food or
provided bail suddenly the trumpists
care about prison reform hilariously but
if you were rallying in support of
rioters it's totally plausible that you
would become violent as well
fortunately washington dc was far better
prepared fortunately it did not become
violent that's good i know that there
were many on the right saying you
liberals want it to be violent no i
wanted it not to be violent we even had
a coupon code during our live stream
saturday which was please no riot we did
not want it to be violent and it was not
but hilariously it did become a complete
and total humiliation a few dozen people
showed up to the event
there were more media people
than actual protesters the protester
attendance was in the dozens whereas the
media presence was in the hundreds now
later we'll be talking about whether the
lack of turnout combined with last
week's disastrous california
gubernatorial recall results are sort of
signaling a waning impact or influence
of trumpism in the republican party i'll
get to that let's first focus on the
rally itself
spectrum news congressional reporter
taylor taylor popolars posted some
observations along with a clip and
noticed several hundred press hundreds
of police
and a few dozen actual rally attendees
couple dozen counter protesters let's
get into some of the rally nonsense our
friend lauren windsor was right there
she filmed a ton of this here is the
organizer matt brainard explaining i
guess the point of the rally which is
really hard to understand
we already have poll numbers that show
essentially half of the public
believes
that the government is holding political
prisoners that came from rasmussen
and it's not it's not partisan
by the way rasmussen disastrous pollster
and they essentially believe i mean this
is this is what we call weasel language
35
of democrats agree with that
in fact yesterday i had a wonderful
interview which is uh you can see the
full live stream because i don't chop it
up but the live full live stream up with
my good new friend from msnbc mr ashman
and after the interview a guy who'd
watched the whole thing
i never recognized before came up and
started to be rather critical of the
line of questioning
saying that it was completely
misrepresenting what this rally was
about they can't hate every person
hitting a police officer
with a fire extinguisher or a violence
like that or destroying doors or other
property with the people who walked in a
few hours later not knowing what they're
doing and are now domestic terrorists
they can't be painted as you can see
it's it's really not clear what this
whole thing is about the same approach
and what was interesting to me is he
said look i'm a liberal democrat
this is about this isn't about president
trump or biden or your political party
it's about human rights and this is
about civil rights
and i'm going to bring somebody up to
say the pledge who has been persistent
okay so then there were prayers and
there was a pledge and there was the
reading of letters there was it it's not
really clear what the whole point of it
was other than to say
the alleged rioters from january 6 are
being not treated well now hilariously
lauren windsor who filmed a lot of this
stuff noticed that most of the security
surrounding matt brainard were black men
she asked him about it afterwards and he
really did not like this line of
questioning why do you have a
predominantly black security board
i have no idea i didn't hire them
no what a dumb question
no
i have no response to that okay so he
found that to be a dumb question um then
and this this is where it starts to get
into sort of outer space
they started doing a say her name thing
with ashley babbitt now remember ashley
babbitt was a trespassing criminal
aggressor on january 6th tragically she
was killed by an officer
an investigation has been done the
officer was cleared in any other
situation if this had been an antifa
protest on january 6th or blm or
whatever
these right-wingers would be say folks
support back the blue the officer was
cleared
now they're uh essentially martyring
ashley babbitt look at this
ashley babbitt roseanne boilings
[Music]
ashley fabric rosa boylan ashley babbitt
rose and boylan ashley
thank you you know they say don't
glorify
criminals they said george floyd
shouldn't be a hero all this stuff
by their own standards the officer was
investigated and cleared
ashley babbitt was tragically killed by
police but she was there trespassing and
in violation of the law
and believed to have been engaged in the
rioting and they would be saying if it
were anybody and if the cause of the
protest was anything other than try to
steal the election for trump they would
be saying the officer
behaved beautifully so this is all wacky
now then it really got nuts in this next
clip
an angry
apparently cuanon woman
starts to get really angry with lauren
for covering the event
why is so upset where are you yeah i'd
like to know i'm tired of everybody the
race car beings on that all the time we
love everybody
we love everybody red yellow black white
we're all the same we're americans it's
always been the melting pot of the world
you young people absolutely hate america
what in the world
is in america that is a meltdown
i don't know what kind of questions were
you asking over there i mean i think
it's a relevant question if you're
saying that you're not a white
supremacist rally if it's in the
majority of the security guards
you don't think that that's a pr move
you don't think that was deliberately
done
no i don't know
oh my god
so now the woman is getting really up
and look she's so close to lauren
windsor that she's off camera
i don't care i will see your ass so fast
[Music]
okay so so that was pretty wacky and
then one last interesting this was
actually interesting i love it when
there's these conflicts between
people who have sort of like an identity
wrapped up in for example in this case
firefighters this is super interesting
this is a different um reporter richard
hall
um a firefighter in uniform comes over
to talk to reporter richard hall and
starts saying the trump riots on january
6 were a false flag it was just it was
staged fake what you know whatever they
mean by a false flag that's what it was
and then another firefighter not in
uniform overhears this and comes over
and says this guy doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about look at this
january 6th i mean you saw the violence
and you know i mean
history will
prove me wrong that that was a false
flag history will reveal that hey i'm a
firefighter too and this guy is talking
pure [ __ ] there is no question
that what happened on january 6th
uh is the work
of people uh supporters of donald trump
right uh who decided
falsely and without any proof that the
21 election
i'd love to hear you next
my name is by the way brother my name is
eric lamar
l-a-m-a-r
and uh
i'm a retired firefighter uh
i would never occur to me to come down
here wearing my wearing my class days
you're retired um and
you're inviting me to do that huh
that was a retirement i'm saying that
this what you're seeing right here folks
is part of the problem
and it's someone
and i almost meant to say this
that is uh from a highly respected fire
department this guy is attacking
um and i have i have the utmost respect
for my brothers and sisters at fdny and
certainly for someone who not only is a
captain but as you can see looks the
part and he's coming down here today and
he's spreading live yep that's
beautifully said beautifully said and
that's
you know the and the use of the guy
pointing out i wouldn't come down here
wearing my classes but i think that's
the equivalent of like in the military i
think it would be like your dress
uniform i wouldn't be down here doing
that
either way and then spreading lies under
that guy is absolutely horrifying so
what's the good news there was no
violence
barely anyone showed up it's really the
best possible outcome which will get us
into our next topic today which is
whether the influence of trumpism is
evaporating
there are two major parties in the
united states in politics there's
republicans and there's democrats that's
the situation right now those are the
two major parties and for about five
years now basically since 2016 the
republican party has become the party of
trump
controlled by trump taken over by
trumpists other flavors of republicans
including increasingly pushed to the
margins yeah it's globally embarrassing
for the u.s
yeah it's completely shameful but it is
the reality the republican party has
become mostly the party of trump in
thinking about the future we've been
wondering will the republican party
continue to be the party of trump or are
they going to abandon that we're not
really going to get our first major data
point until november of 2022 when the
midterm elections actually take place
we'll be able to see do the trumpian
incumbents get re-elected do the trump
endorsed candidates win that type of
thing in november of 22 but short of
those results we just received in the
last week two pretty important data
points that could signal a declining
influence of trumpism what are the two
data points well first of all last week
we had the california gubernatorial
recall election it was heavily pushed
forward
by pro-trump republicans in california
the primary alternative to the incumbent
governor gavin newsom was nothing short
of a trump clone in larry elder and the
republicans got crushed
64-36 just a massive defeat this is
basically the same margin as joe biden's
2020 win in california of 63-34
and in a recall usually those calling
for the recall are highly motivated to
vote and yet they still got crushed by
the same margin that biden defeated
trump in california in last year's
election usually you would expect a
tighter race in that case
in a sense that was a mini referendum on
donald trump and it went absolutely
terribly for the pro-trump california
republicans so that's data point number
one from last week
secondly over the weekend we had this
completely failed pro-trump rioter rally
in washington dc
and people like congressman ted lou and
others have been saying
the pathetic turnout shows the waning
influence of donald trump now alone i
don't think these two data points really
tell us what we need to know about
trumpism in the republican party but
they're interesting data points
regardless importantly even if we
believed that these were real true bona
fide signs of donald trump's declining
influence it would not be a signal for
us to just sit back so in that sense
it's irrelevant this is going to be a
long process in the best of cases and
ultimately it's going to come down to
the 2022 election
if republicans lose seats somehow and if
trumpists lose
it may be the end of the clown show
locally they might still do okay but
nationally you could see in november of
22 the republican party if they if they
get crushed they will probably go back
to something other than trumpism
something marginally less bad still bad
but marginally less bad and trump may
see those 2022 results as a sign that he
should not run in 2024. now the
alternative is trump is do well in 2022
or even if trump is don't do that well
but republicans gain in the house take
the house it might still encourage trump
to say i think i'm going to go for it in
2024. so for now
even if trump is losing influence
trumpism is still very much alive most
republicans still repeat his talking
points they still fear monger
the way that he does they still placate
the it's rigged ideology and the type of
people now there's one other side to
this
there were some trumpists saying don't
go to the dc rally this weekend it's a
false flag they're going to use it to
entrap you the fbi is actually setting
it up now in that sense if that's what
kept people away to the point where only
a few dozen actually showed up it may
also not be the signal that we imagine
it to be but there are some
cautious reasons to wonder
is the influence of trumpism waning as
evidenced over the last two weeks over
the last week by the pathetic turnout
over the weekend at the justice for j6
rally and the humiliating disastrous
defeat for republicans in california let
me know what you think how valuable
how important
are these data points in these signals
you can find me on twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on curiositystream i'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library i just finished watching
becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com
slash
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
remember that our program is mostly
funded by viewers and listeners like you
who sign up at joinpackman.com we do an
extra show every day if you like this
show even at all i mean come on if you
like it at all
you can get an extra show every single
day by signing up at joinpakman.com you
can also use the coupon code better21 to
get a discount off of the membership of
your choice all right let's talk about
an incredible story that's both
incredible for what it contains but also
because of some of the reaction that
we've seen from some
the pentagon has admitted to killing 10
civilians including up to seven children
in a kabul drone strike last month
this particular drone strike was the
center of much controversy because it
tied in with the withdrawal from
afghanistan that donald trump initially
said he wanted to do wasn't able to do
and joe biden ultimately did
we now have video of a centcom commander
general kenneth mackenzie saying
we didn't get terrorists we got
civilians
um the u.s is considering reparation
payments to surviving family members the
pentagon originally said the strike
killed two isis-k fighters believed to
be involved in planning attacks against
u.s forces in kabul the drone strike
came after a suicide bomb attack by
isis-k
that resulted in the deaths of 13 u.s
service members and dozens of afghans
near kabul's airport so we're going to
look at video of general kenneth
mackenzie
saying i apologize for this and then
there's a few different things that i
want to talk about but
to go into it to kind of frame this the
reason this particular drone strike is
getting so much attention is the context
in the withdrawal from afghanistan as
retaliation to the isis k suicide
bombing near the airport that left 13
service members and more civilians dead
let's listen i am now convinced that as
many as 10 civilians including up to
seven children were tragically killed in
that strike moreover we now assess that
it is unlikely that the vehicle and
those who died were associated with isis
k or were a direct threat to u.s forces
okay so so far
killed civilians
didn't kill isis k okay
i offer my profound condolences to the
family and friends of those who were
killed
this strike was taken in the earnest
belief that it would prevent an imminent
threat to our forces and the evacuees at
the airport but it was a mistake
and i offer my sincere apology
as the combatant commander i am fully
responsible for this strike and this
tragic outcome so it seems
incongruous
to be talking about a strike which was
supposed to get isis k
but got 10 civilians including seven
children and saying i'm sorry guys
sorry we didn't get the terrorists we
got 10 civilians and i get that it's
completely incongruous it's like
visually shocking you are am i really
hearing this is this how they're talking
about it
this happens all the time
this particular drone strike got more
attention
because of the circumstances surrounding
it we've been talking about the issue of
drone strikes killing civilians
for a decade i mean we started really
talking about it in earnest under barack
obama the drone program under the obama
administration was one of the biggest
foreign policy criticisms of the obama
administration
jenk yuger our friend from the young
turks had a nice series of tweets about
pointing to
this outrage
it may or may not be real
the media outrage in response to this
admission from the from the centcom
commander but it's actually another data
point of the media being against the
afghanistan withdrawal jenk explains it
let's look at these tweets jenk wrote
quote all the reporters who were
outraged by pentagon drone strike that
killed civilians are you guys not aware
that we've been killing civilians with
drone strikes for decades how is this
news to you that you are all of a sudden
bothered by it because almost none of
you objected before jenk going on to say
interestingly
this outrage comes as a continuation of
corporate media rage over the withdrawal
from a war this outrage did not at all
exist in the middle of those wars but
now quote reporters are pissed that the
pentagon makes mistakes
please jank is spot on here
it is great that the pentagon has taken
responsibility for something horrifying
okay it's great that they're considering
payments payments which of course don't
bring family back but what else can you
do now other than get throw money at a
problem right um but this isn't new and
there is a very cynical nature to this
and it's analogous to the media reaction
to the withdrawal from afghanistan as i
said before the withdrawal was 100 the
right thing to do
uh had trump done it would have been uh
extremely complicated
similar things would have happened biden
did it got us out of a war there has
been more criticism
from the media
corporate centrist media
and right-wing media and even left-wing
media to some degree of biden getting
out there's been more scrutiny of biden
getting out than there was of the 20
years that we spent there and in the
same way it's not that this drone strike
is irrelevant it's it's horrifying it's
a tragedy it's
should it be criminal right i mean we
okay there's no mitigation about this
particular drone strike
but it's being used by some in the media
to further reinforce the idea that
leaving afghanistan was a mistake when
if they cared about drone strikes they
could have been covering the drone war
for the last decade differently than
they did and they haven't been doing it
and so it's hard to take it all
seriously good for jenk for pointing
this out good that they took
responsibility on video in this way but
this is not a new thing that doesn't
change the seriousness of this
particular drone strike but we've got to
understand this in context and
understand the way in which it's useful
to the people that are reporting on it
in certain ways
hey this is really really interesting
there's this channel called newsmax it's
a crazy channel
and they have a host named grant
stinkfield
and this guy went nuts when a veteran
went on and issued it's like the mildest
most milquetoast critique of donald
trump the whole point was
all of this terrible stuff is happening
in afghanistan and it's biden's fault
and
the the veterans simply tried to say
hey you know um
it also like sort of would have been
trump's thing too like trump had the
same plan it was like the mildest
critique and grant stinkfield melts down
throws the guy off and says you are not
going to criticize trump on this channel
whoa pretty serious journalism huh guys
let's take a look at this i i can tell
you this this didn't happen under
president trump and i know there's a lot
of people on the left that want to try
to blame president trump he wanted out
of afghanistan real bad he was real
frustrated not being able to get out but
he didn't pull out because he knew this
would happen in fact we all did i called
it on this program my 12 year old son
knew about it and so um i've got
americans there that are stuck
to me that's a hostage situation but joe
i appreciate you working to get them out
i really do and i wish you all
respect
with your respect grant i mean like
veterans you know being one right and
our friends are over there um right we
followed this closely from multiple
administrations and
we know that trump's administration's
efforts here were fairly weak that they
were trying to limit the number of
people that would get out this is like
the mildest critique first coordination
problems joe i'm gonna joe i'm gonna cut
you i i'm already i'm already weak i'm
already low on time joe joe cut him off
please cut him off now cut him off now
you're not gonna blame this on president
trump on my show no it's not happening
now i appreciate the work that you're
doing god bless you for being a veteran
god bless you for trying to get
americans out but don't come on this
program and take the talking point to
the left and blame president trump
that's not helping anybody the bite
administration screwed this up from the
very start you know it i know it the
country knows it and you call them not
hostages i don't know how you don't call
them hostages they're stuck in
afghanistan with a country overrun with
terrorists this guy's out of his mind i
mean he's completely disconnected from
reality that are willing to kill them
all
i'm mad about that man i really am
how dare you question my narrative
veteran but we support the troops yeah
god bless god bless all right
we're gonna slow it down please because
we've got a real hero coming up that
man's a real hero too he served
before i get caught saying that that
veteran is not a hero what happened to
respecting the troops right i mean that
was you know um both of you whoa
covered the trump white house video out
of nowhere um we have learned that
support the troops
is
support the mission of republican
presidents they don't really care about
troops they don't really care about the
opinion of individuals if it conflicts
with their view if it's not useful to
their cause and look at the mental
gymnastics that are going on there he's
trying not to insult the troops he even
says we're going to talk to a real hero
next but not that guy's not a hero but
we're not going to allow it on this show
no no no no no
god bless you
except you're an ignorant leftist
sympathizer but god bless you you're i'm
not saying you're not a hero but you
know the next guy's really a hero
because he won't criticize trump how
this is not a skit is
unbelievable i mean this this this is a
parody
of the support the troops ideology
support the troops yeah but this guy he
criticized the dear leader so all of a
sudden he is not a hero but sort of but
not as much as the next guy that i'm
going to bring on incredible stuff
happening over on newsmax and it
actually it's worth
seeing it because it is pushing the
lines on hypernationalism well beyond
fox news very very interesting we'll
have more coverage of what took place
there on our instagram you can find us
on instagram at david pakman show find
me on instagram david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right i'm gonna show you here a
video that is like the perfect storm of
the most perverted anti-vaxx insanity
combined with the continued absurdity
and hypocrisy of fox hosts who work for
a company that has a stricter vaccine
policy than what joe biden outlined a
couple of weeks ago continuing to gin up
their audiences
by giving air airtime to the wackiest
most unhinged anti-vaccine and
anti-science voices who am i talking
about i'm talking about comedian jim
brewer
and fox news host tucker carlson this
you have to see this to believe it as
huffington post writes this i love this
headline
saturday night live's goat boy meaning
meaning jim brewer rants about the beast
barks like a seal
in a wild anti-vax rant now there's two
elements to this first it's the nonsense
that jim brewer says
second it's tucker nodding along and
saying right and praising jim brewer for
saying this stuff and then in addition
to that the fox audience who thinks wow
tucker's really standing up for what he
believes is right
fox news not only requires vaccination
or testing otherwise
if you're not vaccinated you've got a
test every day at fox remember biden
said every week you get a test every day
at fox and you got to wear masks as well
that's stricter than ju so tucker works
there but on air he does the anti-vaxx
apologia so let's get right into it this
is crazy brewer seems out of his mind
but the principle remains if you can
force people to get the vaccine what
can't you do right that's a question
that jim brewer appears to be thinking
about he's a comedian he just announced
he's not performing at any venue that
requires patrons to be vaccinated yeah
so that's the gist of this that jim
brewer said
i'm canceling shows where the venue says
everybody's got to be vaccinated and now
he's a hero
joins us tonight to explain why jim
brewer thanks so much for coming on
interesting that you did this it caught
our attention why tell us
i'll be quiet as you explain why you did
this yeah
well
honestly
i got a lot of feedback from a couple
venues that i was playing
my fans were really upset they said you
know
i'm not comfortable with getting a
covered shot and and now they're saying
i can't come see you perform unless i do
that
and i looked into it and
that's the last thing
you should be doing
is going hey you want to come you want
to come see the like feeding the seal
the fish hey you want to you want to
come see a concert or
that's funny guys he's barking like a
seal this is a he's it's a good it's the
point is better because he's barking i
wanna here catch the fit why would you
do that why would you i don't want any
of my fans
forced
to come laugh
and they got to get a shot in them okay
so as much as
as much as jim brewer might love it for
people to be forced to go to his show
no one's being forced to do anything
it's comedy is optional okay if they
don't want to get a shot then they don't
have to go to the show they can go to a
different show or they can look at his
clips online or they can do it
nobody's being forced to go to comedy
shows at all as much as jim brewer might
love it if it was mandatory to go to his
comedy it's not
and and honestly tucker i got to be
honest with you what really what really
started uh my video
was there's a new narrative
and the new narrative is the
unvaccinated or the beast kill the beast
this this this program and car notice
tucker says exactly that's an idea
tucker's been pushing he did it with
some
candidate on his daytime show the guy
said i think that i think the left wants
to kill the unvaccinated and tucker's
like absolutely goes on forever kill the
beast the beast is the unvaccinated
kill them and when when our leader you
can tell his comedy's really funny
put that out there and pointed the
finger like we're the demons
i'm not vaccinate i had covet you're not
gonna tell me
about my body i know i i know my body i
know my morals i know my faith you don't
come telling me and threaten me and
everyone else as if we're the demons i
have so at this point we're not even on
planet earth you know you don't come
threaten me as if i'm the demon
what he's talking about is
biden said
if you have over 100 employees they
should be vaccinated or test weekly
and then venues are legally able to
require vaccines if they want to jim
brewer is at demons and faith and all
these different things two close friends
right now fully vaccinated and they got
covered yeah and they're both sick so
what is this is not about safety because
if it was you just like you said and i
said in my video
eat more fruit take care of your body
now remember there is no evidence that
eating fruit prevents covid that i guess
they're alluding to
if you're generally healthier
overall your risk of death is lower from
all causes but that's
not specific to covet uh go the gym i've
been saying that forever you would have
thought i called people savages for
doing that but this is where we're at as
society and and the greatest thing i
have to be honest with you please i'm so
blessed because 95
of people i was just saying it to be
honest tucker
one message after the other was
thank you
thank you for speaking up
thank you i feel terrible i'm a fireman
and they want me to get vaccinated i
don't want to get vaccinated my my child
i know someone
my hand to god
so
is it obviously a lie because he said
hand to god i don't know and it was uh
the last vaccine push
their child five years old vaccinated
when paralyzed okay
who's vaccinating five-year-olds
am i missing something has the vaccine
been approved for five years how is who
is this five-year-old that got a vaccine
were they part of a trial
from the neck down and i do a benefit
for a benefit for him every year oh i
guess this oh
oh this is more j so he's saying some
other vaccine paralyzed a kid is that
the claim now so when i hear people
going oh you don't know that no you
don't
okay so a bizarre rant barking like a
seal in opposition to vaccination there
is a jim brewer
and um
that's pretty scary because he's an
entertainer
and all sorts of people just see what he
says and they love it they love it and
they just accept it so that was going on
and tucker carlson absolutely loving it
and praising it okay if you want to get
a sense of how long this election fraud
stuff is going to be going on
um donald trump uh just sent a letter to
the georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger demanding that he be
declared the winner of georgia trump
demanding that trump be declared the
winner of georgia don't check your
calendar this isn't a repeat it really
is mid-september of 2021. it's not
november of 2020. it's not december of
uh 2020. um it's uh it's almost october
of 2021
and uh donald trump is demanding that he
be given the state of georgia in the
november of 2020 election donald trump
sent this letter on friday i fully
expected when i saw this headline i
thought this must be from months ago it
must have just resurfaced like it can't
be from now
but indeed it is
the letter is dated september 17 2021
the letter says
dear secretary raffensberger
large-scale voter fraud cap random
capitalization i still don't understand
it his followers do it too large scale
voter fraud continues to be reported in
georgia
enclosed is a report of 43 000 absentee
ballot votes counted now the count count
it is capitalized guys it the counting
is so important that he's put a capital
c on it in the middle of a sentence
absentee ballots of ballot votes counted
in dekalb county that violated the chain
of custody rules making them invalid
i would respectfully request that your
department check this and if true along
with many other claims of voter fraud
and voter irregularities start the
process of decertifying the election or
whatever the collect correct legal
remedy is and announce the true winner
he's saying announce me as the winner of
georgia it's october
as stated to you previously the number
of false and or irregular votes is far
greater than needed to change the
georgia election result people do not
understand why you and governor brian
kemp adamantly refused to acknowledge
the now proven facts and fight so hard
that the election truth not be told you
and governor kemp are doing a tremendous
disservice to the great state
capitalized of georgia and to our
capital and nation
which is systematically being destroyed
by an ill illegitimate president in his
administration the truth must be allowed
to come out thank you for your attention
to this matter
their argument is that because some
forms were dated a few hours late
i'm interpreting what is being said here
okay
some forms were dated a few hours late
they want
every result from all of those
ballot boxes thrown out and not counted
they want to disenfranchise tens of
thousands of voters
because of some messed up paperwork with
some of these ballots now the law that
they cite is this emergency declaration
which has rules for ballot drop boxes
it doesn't say
if any rule is
violated you throw the all the ballots
in the box into the trash it doesn't
actually say that it doesn't say throw
the votes out and don't count them so
all of this
is being signal boosted by articles
being written that say
because it appears that maybe some
ballots had a uh were a few hours late
in being certified
you need to just throw out all the
ballots from those ballot boxes there's
nothing in the law that suggests that
that should be happening so at this
point is this a mental health issue
is this trolling
is it grifting it was just this letter
was released just before the saturday
rally in support of the trump rioters
maybe it was an indirect way to try to
rile people up remember donald trump
remember when he just asked for 11 000
votes to be found for him i need 11 000
votes give me a break this guy seems
willing to do anything
but again the issue is the burden of
proof he says he has the evidence but he
wants brad raffensberger to prove that
his allegations are true
what this may actually be
is an attempt to preempt
what increasingly seems like is going to
be an investigation
into trump's attempts to overturn the
georgia results this is an article from
friday the same day as this letter came
out
georgia criminal probe into trump's
attempt to overturn 2020 election
quietly moves forward quietly moves
forward so this may be
trump trying to argue look
i wasn't trying to break the law when i
asked for 11 000 votes what i meant is
what i said in this letter which is you
should investigate this and you should
investigate that it's kind of like that
weasley mafioso type speak that we've
become accustomed to from donald trump
but a delusional letter i was convinced
this letter must be six months old no
it's from friday and we will continue to
follow it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's do a
little um let's do almost like a history
lesson type segment here i have an
example for you today of something that
the modern republican party is now
regularly engaging in that is
indistinguishable from standard
historical
fascist propaganda it checks all the
boxes today we're going to be comparing
it specifically to
italian fascist propaganda during and in
the pre-mussolini era it'll all make
sense in a moment come along for the
ride we will start with radical
pro-trump republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor-green's new political
advertisement apparently she's running
in 2022 we were we've been wondering how
many of these trumpets will run in 2022
if they run how many of them are going
to win it's going to be a big piece
of influencing whether or not donald
trump runs in 2024
marjorie taylor green in her new ad says
i guess
if you reelect her she's going to blow
away the democrats socialist agenda
and then in the video she actually blows
up a car a prius
with socialism on it with a 50 cal rifle
that she is also auctioning off
uh for people who contribute to her
campaign like ev every aspect of this is
just a dystopian fascist propaganda
piece let's take a look at it and then
um we're going to discuss okay so here's
the ad see pelosi is sneaking the green
new deal into the 3.5 trillion dollar
budget and in 2022 i'm going to blow
away the democrats socialist agenda
[Music]
[Music]
go to the website below and sign up to
win my 50 caliber yeah so the website
she refers to is is
greengun.com
this is straight up fascist propaganda
and it's an it's potentially an
incitement to violence because she's
normalizing
shooting socialist priuses right i mean
it's it's not even an analogy she's
shooting a socialist prius in the car so
we have a ton of examples of fascist
propaganda this is just another example
when you look for examples of the
propaganda of fascist italy leading up
to and during the mussolini era
it's this type of stuff i'm going to
tell you the themes of this is now these
are the themes of italian fascist
propaganda
very well known historically and look at
how much it applies to marjory taylor
green number one personality cults
around individuals this is not marjorie
taylor green talking about policy
this is marjorie taylor green
building a cult of personality around
her as a socialist
gun totor who blows up
socialist priuses right that's what it
is
action over talk as a form of politics
was a theme of italian fascist
propaganda marjorie taylor green
shooting a gun at a socialist car she's
not talking about issues she's not
talking about solving problems like an
adult she's using action over talk as
the default of politics um from okay so
now this one because marjorie taylor
green is a woman we have to think a
little bit differently about this one
but for mussolini and italian fascism
fertility and the strength of men was a
big thing this is kind of like a female
version of it although there's not as
direct of an analogy of marjorie taylor
green
uh uh
appearing to be
more likely to bear children on the
basis of shooting guns but there's also
a bit of a masculinization of marjorie
taylor green so so maybe it does
actually apply that's another one
attacking foreign culture
in italy it was americanism that was
attacked
french and russian literature were
attacked etc
in this case with marjory taylor green
it's the pseudo-foreign culture of
american socialists they're not
foreigners but the idea is they aren't
like us they're not really americans in
the mold that we believe americans
should exist so very similar
um and then of course italian fascist
propaganda was anti-democratic and it
was anti-small l liberalism
shooting your political opponents is not
democratic this is again about firearms
as solutions
the use of slogans to cover
the violence of what you propose okay
that was a common thing at the eight
second mark in this video which i will
pull up for you it says in 2022 i'm
going to blow away the democrats
socialist agenda
and notice she blows up a toyota prius a
sort of emblem of what they don't like
prius you know one of the first hybrid
vehicles now available as a plug-in car
even that detail is rev relevant to the
fascistic nature of the propaganda it's
a fight for foss or fossil fuels we're
not no silly hybrids or electric cars
now that's the analysis with fascist
propaganda from italy um
just you know you could you could do it
with something else altogether but we've
just picked that
and our friend and fellow argentinian
federico finkelstein
who is an expert on fascism actually
tweeted in response to this video
fascist propaganda 101
we have to be calling this for what it
is lots of politicians
blowing things up
taliban style
to make political points about how bad
liberals are and how the left has to be
punished and meanwhile if you propose
like a child tax credit
that's called socialist by these very
same people they're disseminating actual
fascistic propaganda but if you want
like health care for people or a child
tax credit or enhanced unemployment then
you are you are called a socialist it's
really dangerous stuff and unfortunately
if it's not uh sort of rooted out um it
it's going to increasingly become more
and more common that we see it why
because they've abandoned policy
altogether notice that there's no policy
there there's no there's no po it's just
we're gonna block we're gonna blow away
the socialists and block nancy how does
she pronounce it pelosi
um etc they're going to keep doing this
type of stuff unless somebody somebody
or something stops them or unless it
loses them elections because they've
given up on policy years ago we've
talked about that before
let's go now from marjory taylor greene
to another radical ignorant trumpist uh
i am talking about
constitutional scholar madison cawthorne
just kidding he's not a constitutional
scholar
he's actually a radical authoritarian
pro-trump congressman who said
um it is against the law for airlines to
require vaccines for travel now they're
not doing that yet but i hope that they
do in fact we know from public opinion
polls that requiring vaccines to get on
an airplane to fly between u.s states
would be extremely effective in getting
the anti-vaxxers to go and get a
vaccination and we're going to play a
clip in which madison cawthorne actually
says you have a constitutionally
protected right to free unrestricted
travel within the united states and it's
one of those examples where a little bit
of knowledge can become a very dangerous
thing when you misunderstand it let's
listen to madison cawthorn we should be
encouraging them to reject this
this is a medical apartheid plain and
simple there's over a hundred million
americans who are not vaccinated i think
it's even more than that
and if they want to start shutting down
air travel for these people to get
around the country i think that's
actually a constitutional violation
because you actually have a
constitutionally protected right to free
unrestricted travel within the united
states of america and i genuinely
believe that what's going on right now
is that all that's going to happen if
united airlines and american airlines
and delta even if they decide to start
requiring vaccine mandates let me tell
you i'm very confident there will be
another air carrier that will come to
the field and patriots like myself and
you will give them all of our business
now that last part is fine if aaron if
airlines like united american and delta
say we're going to require vaccines
it's completely plausible
that someone else will come forward and
say we do not require vaccines now
if airlines are mandated to require
vaccines by the federal authority of the
department of transportation then that
won't happen but if it's a decision made
by individual airlines madison may well
be right some anti-vax airline might
come forward and the anti-vax people
like madison or whoever grant grant
stinkfield they can go and fly that but
here's where a little bit of knowledge
gets people in trouble madison catherine
repeats
you have a constitutionally protected
right to free unrestricted travel within
the united states therefore an airline
requiring a vaccine would be
unconstitutional this is a really good
teachable moment
you would hope that members of congress
would know this but they don't first of
all what we're talking about here is the
right to travel domestically under
constitution and the federal law
now it's important to understand that
it's never been substantially questioned
or limited judicially it's it that
that's absolutely true
but
in 1941 the supreme court declared it
unconstitutional for california to just
restrict the migration of so-called
okies
um and that uh there is a right of free
movement as a right of national
citizenship and that that has to be that
that has been upheld under the commerce
clause but there are exceptions there
are exceptions in a 1985 case the
supreme court found that the privileges
and immunities clause prohibits
discrimination against a non-resident
from us from one state from from another
state in one state
except where number one there is a
substantial reason for a different
treatment
non-vaccinated status could be such a
reason and number two when the
discrimination practiced against
non-residents bears a substantial
relationship to the state's objective if
a state as an objective has
reduced covered spread
you could see a limitation on the
ability to freely travel between states
but but but more importantly
both the president
and
the department of hhs
and governors have powers when there's a
public health emergency that can
supersede the right to travel but throw
all of that stuff away like forget about
all of that
because there's a bigger issue
just because you can legally
move between states that doesn't mean
airlines have to allow you on their
flights and allow you to ignore their
requirements what i mean by that is free
travel when it's not not limited by
emergencies okay let's imagine there's
no limitation on travel by any governor
no there's free travel that generally
means if you can get yourself to a
border of another state you can go into
that state you can drive in you can walk
in whatever it doesn't mean
that if there's a specific airline and a
specific flight
that requires vaccines they have to let
you on if you're not vaccinated imagine
saying there's free travel between
states i don't have to be subjected to
tsa security
because the constitution grants me free
travel between states come on guys
get in a car and drive over there but
that can't be used to say you get to
skip security and along the same lines
as long as vaccine requirements are
generally legal for airlines to put in
place which as far as we know right now
they are it is just as legal for an
airline as a policy to say we require
proof of vaccination for passengers or
we require proof of vaccination for
employees or both
they really don't get it but they come
up with stuff that to lower information
news consumers sounds good hey i do have
a right to free travel between states by
the constitution sure get in a car and
drive over there and assuming the road's
not closed and assuming if it's a toll
road that you pay the toll right all
these things if you can get yourself to
the border you can go in that doesn't
mean you get to go to an airline and say
i'm not abiding by any of your rules i'm
not wearing my seat belt i'm going to be
standing during takeoff i don't want to
go through security and i don't want to
be vaccinated it's just not the way it
works and unfortunately madison
cawthorne continues to convince people
with this stuff he's admitted he's not
running a policy uh um
office he's running a pr and
communications office and this stuff
gets millions and millions of views and
his followers love it it's all bs
it's all wrong conveys a complete
misunderstanding of what it means to
have free travel between states but his
followers absolutely love it we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
here's a call i got about prageru videos
being shown in school listen to this
hi david
uh i'm a middle school social studies
teacher and i want to share with you
something that happened in my school
this week
so one of my colleagues also social
studies teacher got called into a
meeting with the principal
uh
and afterwards he had told us the story
apparently a parent voiced a concern
about something in his lesson and it
turned out that he had shown the class a
video from prageru
and one of the students uh
noticed this source as something to be
wary of and kind of raised that concern
with the parent who contacted the
um
i just wanted to kind of share that with
you and say you know i thought it was
kind of uh
i was proud that there were students out
there that were uh you know being
considerate and critical of the sources
that they're encountering
absolutely whatever kid did that has
upper management written all over him or
her uh no i mean listen prageru in
social studies that is not good that is
really really not good and i if i had a
kid in school right now um
i would be first of all i would be
losing my mind if they came home and
said sir that's my kids would call me
sir if they said sir um
we were shown prageru videos
but i would be wanting to go out of my
way to prepare them and say listen
you might be shown videos in school
uh you know little rifka or a little
little mordechai you might be shown
videos in school
just because your teacher chooses the
video doesn't mean you can believe
everything in the video you always have
to think for yourself and if you ever
have a question you come to me son or
daughter you know whatever anyway the
point is i'm i'm joking about how i
would say it but i would go out of my
way
to prepare my kids for the fact that
you may be shown things that are not
representative representing the world as
it is and certainly prageru videos and
social studies class would be very very
high on that list but good on that kid
for doing it we have a great bonus show
for you today poverty fell in 2020 why
stimulus checks and enhanced
unemployment very simple we will talk
about walmart and ford teaming up on
self-driving deliveries
and beto o'rourke
is looking like he's going to run for
governor against texas governor greg
abbott i love this and it will give us
another great race a great race for the
coming election cycle all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com get yourself
instant access i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video